منح الاسهم للموظفين ربما هي خطوه من ماسك
للاحتفاظ بالمواهب وطمانتهم بعد موجات
متتاليه من تسريح الاف الموظفين بخلاف
الهلع وحالات الاستقالات الجماعيه داخل
الشركه ماسكا اخبر فريق العمل ان الشركه
مرت بتغيرات جذريه لكنها ضروريه حيث كانت
على بعد اربعه اشهر فقط من الافلاس تستخدم
طريقه منح الاسهم عموما لتحفيز الموظفين
هي فرصه لشراء الاسهم التي لا يمكن بيعها
حتى وقت محدد وقد تدر ربحا جيدا اذا
ارتفعت قيمه الشركه بشكل كبير وكان ماسك
سبق واعتمد هذا النموذج نفسه مع شركته
سبيس اكس في الوثيقه الداخليه يقول ماسك
ان الطريق الى تقييم تويتر باكثر من 250
مليار دولار صعب لكنه واضح وهو ما يعني
ارتفاع قيمه الاسهم بقدر عشره اضعاف